we're down to sunny and warm South
Africa
where a few of my friends are starts in
the afternoon drive and I believe mr.
Scottie Dyson is already on Drive and is
ready to say good afternoon strive in
the Maasai Mara he must be very very
excited my name's Scott and I'm teamed
up with Davi on camera as you can see
we've got lucky and managed to relocate
a portion of the Inca home a pride of
Lion Tristan did find them in the same
spot this morning and well done to him
for finding him because of very very
thick and tricky spots so he did a great
job this morning and it's not the entire
pride we've noticed that over at least
the last week or so that we've been
seeing them quite a bit again is that
there's three lioness that are spending
time away from the rest of the pride and
here it's built up of two adults six
sub-adults and one tiny youngster so
nine lions in total or snoozing here and
I did go out last night with some of the
staff after dinner and we did manage to
find actually both different sets of the
pride they were quite far from one
another but interestingly this portion
definitely looked a bit hungrier than
they do nos I'm guessing there may have
had a small snack during the night I
wonder what they would have caught but
their bellies do seem like they've at
least got something in it
late last night they were looking very
very hungry when we found him at the
puffles of course oh there's a good
example over there and most of the
individuals that we've been looking at
now are the youngsters the sub adults
which there are six of them I think it's
just one boy and five girls and for me
it's just so incredible to see how much
bigger this pride is compared to when I
last left chair it's definitely going to
be a force to be reckoned with the ones
or these five young ladies come of age
and also start having their own cubs so
exciting prospects for the future and
very soon we could have a mega pride
waltzing around Juma
mirror you wondering or not the Lions
down here and Juma maybe slightly darker
than the ones up in the Mara I don't
think so but what you may find is that
the kind of all the different colors and
contrasts and textures of the Mara
creates kind of different canvas on
which we see the line that may look that
make them look a little bit more pale
than the ones here but I certainly
haven't noticed the ones here being any
darker but you are you have a finer
attention to detail an idea and maybe
that's just the problem maybe I'm just
haven't been paying enough attention but
I haven't really noticed major
differences in color in general between
lions the dog is actually not easy to
see from where we are but some of moms
milk and I really hope that this Cub
Cubs health takes a turn for the better
it has conditioned and got a little bit
of a cuff at the moments or at least the
last few days that we've been seeing it
but if the pride continues to be
successful making lots of kills then
it'll definitely improve the chances of
this cub getting rid of its illnesses
we're not entirely sure what could be
wrong with that it could have feline TB
a lot of alliance in the Kruger National
Park do have this wonderful stuff well
we're gonna stay put with this pride in
the hope that they make it up and take
us for a walk who knows maybe something
will stumble into them in this very
thick area that then so they could get
lucky with the meal coming to them and
the meantime there we're gonna stay put
and send you across to Noel to let you
know what her plans are for the
afternoon afternoon everyone we have a
very lovely overcast and cloudy day
which is keeping everything nice and
cool I am a Noel and on camera I would
like to welcome back pilot Fergus hello
pilot Ferg
he's saluting actually we're in a car
she was supposed to salute like this and
amazingly we have juror oh and then of
course they've run away I got so excited
we framed at this beautiful shots and
then of course they move but we have
giraffe we don't get to see a lot of
draw here and they move around and we
have a little journey I've counted three
or four already but we've just got to
this one that we can see nicely here so
this is the southern draft different
there's the big one that we had framed
up and then she decided to meander off
I'm different from the drop you'll see
up there in the Mara
there's Masai giraffe up there and we
have a couple of youngsters and this big
beautiful female and then there was
another female and that's probably
lurking around the corner so we have a
journey or a tower or a kaleidoscope of
draft whichever collective noun you
prefer now something I love about draft
very much is their long long long
eyelashes and also their long tongues
which you just saw her poking hers out
there their tongue is probably over 20
centimeters was one I heard and then off
up to 40 centimeters is another one that
I've read and it's a sort of blueish
black color I've always been told it so
that it doesn't get sunburned and then
those long eyelashes are to help keep
things away from their eyes when they're
busy feeding I think I maybe maybe just
want to pull up a little bit so we can
watch our journey progress on and we're
also gonna be able to see these
beautiful storm clouds that we have
forming in the back so someone's getting
rain it's not us but I do hope that it
will be us at some point today I believe
there's rain forecasted for the whole
week and I'm hoping we get 300 mils that
will be my hope Tom really good question
could these those lines the Inca Houmas
that are over there with Scotty D huntys
giraffe most definitely Tom they would
love a big meal like giraffe and those
females would be very capable of taking
down a draftee sizes now that female
that's there on the right-hand side she
sort of walked into this tree and that's
helping each
spots that she can't reach also helps
take some ticks off beautiful there
we've got a lovely oxpecker on her neck
also helping to take ticks off as many
of you know but many of you may not know
oxpeckers main diet is blood and so they
land on prey species so giraffe impala
Rhino Buffalo zebra and they take those
ticks off but if there's a wound that's
on that animal they'll also keep the
wound open to keep the blood flowing
now I'm really loving that slate slate
grey sky and the colors of this drop in
the background making me happy and the
green foliage mixed in now every giraffe
every subspecies of giraffe has a unique
coat pattern and then every individual
within the species has an individual
pattern like a fingerprint
so the females and the young will live
in a herd and then the male's will
sometimes be in little bachelor groups
little loose associative herds and
sometimes on their own very similar to
many other herd species so for elephants
for instance you'll get females all
together and then the males will
sometimes the adult males will sometimes
be on their own and then sometimes in
little groups now the females are also
known to be in what's known as a loose
associative herd meaning they're not
always very close together like you see
now sometimes they're very spread out so
if you see one female there's probably
more that you just that are not in the
immediate vicinity but probably within
within a hundred meters of each other
and their communications are on
frequencies that we can't necessarily
hear so their distress call is a sound
it's very light and then if they're
being eaten by something like the Incas
they do make a sort of throttling noise
when that happens but the rest of the
communications are on a very low
frequency so for a very long time the
assumption was that drafts were mute
they are in fact not mute it's just
something that aren't ears do not
register and pick up I would be
interested to know if elephants can
register giraffe communications because
elephants have much more sensitive vocal
abilities and are very receptive to
things like the thunder and lightning
that's probably happening on the back
end of that storm elephants here can
recognize that can feel that can hear
that a very good question
wow we're looking at that a beautiful
landscape I'm going to see if in my book
I have any examples to show you but
basically a the the Masai giraffe the
pattern looks like a Canadian Maple Leaf
like on the Canadian flag and for ours
we have more of this block look there's
other species that you'll find up in
that area you get reticulated draft but
the main draft species is Masai giraffe
and on.for
okay I can show you a thornycroft with a
which they've actually regulated as not
a subspecies anymore they've recently
done a lot of DNA testing that's changed
how many subspecies around and how many
species are around but here's our
southern draft okay now notice that the
pattern comes most the way down the legs
and then it's these sort of blocks but
they're blotchy blocks it's not like a
reticulated draft that are very very
square abstract blocks as you will and
then the Thorneycroft over here the
pattern stops this way they're shorter
and the pattern is even more mixed
mixed-media inside inside of there and
then if you can forego I don't know if
you can zoom in on this little one
that's at the tip of my fingertip there
oh sorry I'm sorry for my hat that's
almost like the maple leaf almost like
the maple leaf you'd see on Masai
giraffe so when I started guiding they
said that there was one species of
giraffe and nine subspecies now they're
saying that there's three species of
Jalapa draff and six subspecies and then
they're still doing a little bit of more
research on that now I'm gonna head I'm
gonna head up I'm not gonna head up I'm
actually gonna stay here in Juma but I'm
gonna send you all up back to the Masai
Mara to Steve and Steve oh I hope you're
having an amazing time up there in Kenya
we miss you give Ralph a hug for me and
teyla and Jamie and everybody and say hi
to Meg's and good faith and everybody
that's up that side and then I hope you
have something interesting to show
everybody you whilst you're up there
thanks Noel I miss you guys too and when
I got you I gave everybody a hug anyway
so I think there's already a close-knit
sort of team going but when I get back
I'll be sure to
the more they hug again and what we do
have here what is a trip to the Mara
River folks without spotting a
hippopotamus we have a pot of them here
in the river and we just missed the one
doing its ablutions as it was defecating
it is just off to the right there by the
rocks it might pop up again but it's a
very important ecological sort of thing
in the rivers here there he goes as the
ears of the back there is the hippo
because they feed on grass they take
their grass material and they bring most
of it back down to the river and a lot
of it gets defecated in the river and
now what that does is it produces I mean
its grass so it's very similar digested
to that of the Verano as well as the
elephant apart from the fact that
elephant has bark and twigs and stuff in
it but that grass material just
semidigested it's fermenting gets a
positive into the little dam you or the
river should I say and that is a huge
huge proponents of the diet for the fish
lots of what's the word vegetarian fish
I'm not getting my words right right now
at the Mara River but there's lots of
fish that eat vegetation and eat all
sorts of materials in the river from
algae to plant material to hippo dung
and so then that provides food for your
herons for the fish eagles for the
crocodile and mace mainly what most of
the food crocodiles feed on here is in
fact fish we don't have zebra and
wildebeest crossing by the thousand
every day they only are crossing at a
certain time of the year and it is not
their prime source of food but they feed
on fish and most places else in the
country where we find crocodile they
don't feed on too much meat but mainly
fish and having hippos in the pool
provides the organic material which
feeds the fish which then feeds a huge
amount of trophic animals above them so
very very important and if any of you've
ever been to Dhaka vengo Delta or have
seen the Okavango Delta the entire Delta
itself is managed and kept open by hippo
movement they make these very big
pathways through and they keep the
stream moving the
the sediment from depositing anyway and
that allows movements of warts and that
allows the Delta to perpetuate and I
reckon a place like the Delta would have
well is what it is because of animals
like hippo what is this hippo doing is
moving with some intention towards the
left and not sure it was a male or if
he's just moving there was another hippo
in front of him there or her running if
he was moving across to do a little bit
of a bit of our G bar G which often
happens in in pods of hippo that do sort
of assign themselves little territory
there's the other one to assign
themselves some territory and you don't
see hippos doing too much and when they
are doing something that's got something
to do with territory or reproduction or
feeding other than that they're pretty
docile individuals the one on the left
looks like a female okay that's what I
was talking about you see with the tail
it's busy defecating there that's the
vegetation splattering around in the
river take chaos a question do it hippos
use infrasound I don't think so I mean I
think there are any animals that use
infrasound or elephants bats use form of
sonar echolocation dolphins use sonar
but I don't think hippos are have the
ability I mean they've got the reason
why they have been put in the family of
whales now is because they communicate
and order they're able to anyway but
that's through those large grunts and
stuff I don't don't think there's any
sort of low key frequency that hippos
are communicating with but I you know I
could be wrong but I've never heard of
anything like that before but they
definitely are very loud grunts and
snorts that they do do and they do spend
most of the time and water and as I said
same families hippos but as whales they
give birth in water they mate in water
they suckle in the water they're
communicating water and they're spend
most of their time in water so why not
call them a whale and they also
vegetarian of course
it's definitely something going on
between these two I wonder if that one
of the back is actually a young male
well maybe these are too territorial
bulls that have small little claims to
this pond with very invisible lines that
we are unaware of it's often the case
the territorial boundaries are things we
cannot perceive a lot to do with smell
and maybe some in the case here off some
fecal content and here we go it doesn't
look like a very big hippo by those
teeth there might just be some
youngsters if you get one the left
doesn't look very big so we're here with
this dangerous animal that is
responsible for many human deaths in the
world and we're going to be going down
to South Africa to a good friend of mine
who's got another very dangerous animal
not that dangerous but rather dangerous
so sounds like you're having a good time
at the Mara River with Stephen the
hippos we've just been sitting here
patiently kind of planning our attack
for the afternoon and we think it's
probably in our best interest to head
off for about 45 minutes to an hour or
so these guys are all looking quite
comatosed for the time being so we'll
probably do a bit of snooping about see
if we can't find any sign of Tandy
Lepidus and a young cub we all
desperately trying to work out where
they are so do a kind of loop around the
general area and see if we can't find
any sign and come back here a little bit
later once these guys seem to wake up
hopefully wake up a little bit later on
like I said I'm fairly convinced that
they did catch something last night and
I was surprised that they were found in
this area because from where we saw them
at Buffalo quartz or last night it
survives
she's a kilometer you know half a mile
from there to here and I would have been
surprised that they've moved such a
short distance considering they were all
quite hungry when when we saw them so I
think they had a small snack maybe an in
yellow or an Impala something you know
that would have got at least something
into all of their bellies there is of
course quite a few lions here that's why
it's not too easy to notice that they've
had a snack
but I'm confident they have so seeing as
though they're not absolutely starving I
don't think they're going to get up
anytime soon
afternoon it's by far the coolest
afternoon we've had in quite some time
and I'm hoping this cool weather brings
us a little bit of rain later on we are
desperate for some rain Kathy you'd like
to know if these youngsters are doing
any hunting with the adults yet not that
I'm aware of they could well be getting
to that kind of stage of their lives
where they could contribute to the ants
but I'm guessing they're not kind of
fully involved for the time being they
could probably look and the outskirts
and the background and contributes if
and when some of the fleeing animals are
run into them and that's very often the
case with lions because there are
multiple members and the pride when they
ambush their predict and sometimes get
lucky and send
and members and I remember sitting with
a pride of lions very similar set up to
actually exactly what we're experiencing
here they were lying up in very thick
bush there's a similar amount of lions
and was also just a couple of adult
lioness and quite a few youngsters just
like we're seeing here although those
youngsters were considerably younger
than these guys there were probably only
a year old these guys I'm guessing are
closer to two years of age now I'm not
actually sure how old they are so if any
of you could help us with had info I
really appreciate that and what happened
was the lioness got up and started
stalking we weren't sure what because it
was very thick vegetation like this and
we heard the ambush kind of take place
and we heard hooves and bushes breaking
and all of a sudden and parlour and
straight into all the one-year-old cubs
and they instinctively latched onto the
sand parlor and could subdue it for long
enough for the adults to return and
dispatch its I guess that's an example
of our even young cubs may not have the
skills required but could sometimes have
some luck with helping the pride doing
some hunting we said
- sure haven't been lucky enough to see
them hunting mister q-tip you'd like to
know how many lines are in this pride
well in this portion of the pride that
we looking at now there's one tiny
youngster who's here we can see touching
over there I think it's nursing no it's
not it's just sleeping so there's that's
the smallest one and then it's got five
sorry six slightly all the cousins which
comprise of I think it's five young
girls and one young boy and then two
adult lioness so there's nine in total
here but the honor the three adult
lioness that are fragmented from the
pride that we saw not too far from here
actually last night but we're not too
sure where they ended up in the early
hours of this morning so in total there
are twelve lions in the Inca home of
pride but only of which four are adults
sorry five are adults my abacus is a bit
rusty clearly I'm still astounded at how
Tristan found these guys in here this
morning he did an incredibly good job
and well done to him for pulling that
off because it really is a tricky area
wonderful stuff well it's not just lions
down here in the sabi sands of South
Africa it sounds like Jaime has got
lucky up in the Mara Lions in the sabi
sands are Lions in the Mara and what
else are Sundays for but for relaxing
lying back and cat napping and in this
particular case a cat napping on a very
freshly dug a pile of dirt that is not
why I am late this afternoon I am late
this afternoon because I had many
problems and that is not a personal
confession I literally had many problems
to do with vehicles and broadcasting but
we're back up we're out and about and we
are with the oh la la la pride all 14 of
them that I've been able to count now
but that doesn't mean that they're not
prizant and accounted for just a quick
introduction for those of you that have
a perhaps just discovered this live
stream my name is Jamie and ER this
afternoon Manu is on camera with me for
the first time in ages Manu it really it
has been a while I don't forget because
this is a live Safari hashtag Safari
live is how you can get hold of us to
ask your burning questions on lions and
other creatures of the African
wilderness and other aspects of the
African wilderness I'm waiting patiently
because every time that I have come to
the spot
neeyala Lawler's have just been lying
doing nothing but then every time that
wolf has come to the spot he has had
them climbing trees and doing acrobatics
and hula hooping and balancing balls on
their noses I'm hoping that as it gets a
little bit cooler that's what they have
in store for us this afternoon and just
in case you're wondering about the
freshly dug dirt let me just mention it
now this is what's known as a borrow pit
so you'll see that there's lots and lots
of places where the earth has clearly
been excavated lions don't have a feel
necessarily for for posing or picture
picking the most picturesque place to be
they go where it's comfortable and this
is very comfortable for them but it has
been artificially dug it is what's known
as a burrow pit for the roads so for the
repair and maintenance of the roads dirt
gets dug up and that's where the all
alors have decided to settle and you can
imagine the dirts still nice and damp so
on a hot Sunday afternoon when the Sun
is blazing down actually probably really
comfortable for them it's all soft it's
not compact on other place and like it
is in other places and that's a really
good snuggle position it's all loose and
comfy and nice and cool and you will
notice at some point or another that
there are other vehicles in the sighting
they all are low lows are an extremely
popular lion pride they have been so
reliable over the last few days this
morning when we caught up with them on
the Sunrise Safari briefly they were
being chased by the resident herd of
what we termed Duggar boys old buffer
balls and one random buffalo cow
actually and they were chasing they were
chasing the Lions round and there was no
real threat to the Lions the Cubs are
now all large enough to be able to
escape and fend for themselves and have
a little bit of common sense now they
immediately sort of snuck away and went
to lie in the shade a few just just far
enough that the Buffalo couldn't do
anything about it just to taunt them and
keep them on edge a little bit Mary you
say that are those lions look exactly
how you feel they look exactly how I
feel as well Mary after our series of
complications this afternoon at a sense
of relief that all is now working well
that's how I'm feeling I'm almost at the
point if they weren't actually wild
lions that I'd be tempted to go and join
them and lovely to hear a Scarlett's
name again now Scarlett's wondering
about a question that we answered
recently actually and something that
we've discussed and it might be
worthwhile getting the other guides
opinions as well
now Scarlett's wondering what the
largest lion pride is that we've ever
seen no I've never seen the the famous
super pride and I've lived around the
lebombo mountains in the Kruger Park
apparently apparently at one point there
were over 40 members strong but very
seldom seen all together the largest
pride that I have seen has been over 20
I never managed to successfully do a
head count but around about 20-25 lions
possibly there have been times in my
life where I've seen even more lions but
I can't think of any at the time
I mean 17 lines is quite a large pride
it's a relatively large pride 13 of them
are Cubs so there's no guarantees until
they reach their first year at which
point their chances of survival
increased dramatically these Cubs still
have a long way to go they're definitely
out of the most risky risky time of
their lives though they're no longer
small and delicate and hiding away all
the
and their mothers don't have to leave
them hidden in potentially dangerous
places they don't look as though they're
under feeling under threat at all they
couldn't look more comfortable if
they're tried now I have to tell you
that this morning as Steve was in his
absolute element when it came to the
birds that we were seeing on his first
drive off the Mara it sounds like he is
continuing his birding streak and we are
back with some beautiful birds one of
them is the Sandpiper I'm not sure which
one I'm pologize for leaving my app at
home today and the other one is a snipe
but folks look how beautiful they are in
contrast but what I really wanted to
look at is look at the feeding depth
that the snipe is able to achieve with
that beak look how far into the mud it
can probe oh look at that a little bit
of a dance we'll have the wag of the
tail look how much further can dig its
beak into the mud then this then the
Sandpiper can do I think it's a green
Sandpiper but I'm not sure something
spooked them very very beautiful it's
nice to be able to see them in the open
like this and what I love about the
birds and their beaks is a different
feeding that they have and whenever you
look at a bird you can often find five
10 15 different types of species in and
around an area and they are not
competing because of our the length of
their legs or the length of their beak
or the shape of the beak so it enables
them to compete for different food the
soonest birds are too similar they are
compete each other and displace each
other it's not often you find animals
that will compete without displacing and
that's why you find large predators
medium-sized predators you don't find
two species of lion anymore and when you
find one because the the niche would
only fit for one of that type so that's
what happens in birds whenever you see
the length and the beak it's very
interesting
yes natural the snipe has got beautiful
coloring and I believe that's a painted
snipe and what's interesting about it is
that when we look in the bird Kingdom
normally in the bird Kingdom what do we
see we see that the feed that is the the
sand pipe if we just go to the other one
please Adrian there we go it's just
forward middle of your screen I think
that is the mail is not very pretty but
the female is very attractive because
the female is actually a little bit of a
other what would you say she likes to go
out and look pretty and have all the men
so he obviously the the males like to
choose the female when it comes to snaps
and she has more than one mate and she
will not look after her chicks she's
very naughty like that he will do all of
the work so it's lovely to see beautiful
birds like this and there's not many in
the bird Kingdom where the female is
more attractive than the male but when
it comes to snaps that is the way they
roll but I just love how they are
competing at various similar areas on
the mudflats there for any sort of
insects in the mud and the the longer
beak you can see the sand pop and the
leaf is just picking whatever can off
the surface it's not really allowing it
too much feeding depth but then the legs
are bit longer so it can probably
weighed more then the snipe could do a
snap has given up doing his activity
they call it needling I'm gonna stick
that beak in quite deep you see it with
hoop who's the ground hoop who's they
walk around there what the not a normal
common Hoopoe they're jabbing their beak
in looking for any form of insects on
the floor obviously the schnapps beak is
very straight and we're watching it go
right up to it's up to it's nasal
passages this or add up to the end of
the beak in the mud and that it's a
really nice depth and also enables them
to preen a little bit easier as you can
see the long beak like that helps you
just scratch further back is it some
birds fly by and the picture and if you
saw that but the snap got a bit of a
fright you know this is for me the first
time I've seen a snap just out in the
open just sort of hanging around
normally they sort of concealed in sort
of
quite bushy undergrowth on the side of
the dam or river they don't often spend
too much time just out in the open so
it's nice to be able to see them doing
that very very special and if we pan to
the left something that is what we first
saw you can see that wonderful tail over
there little pan of water in the side of
this river we have got a Nile crocodile
lettuce gentlemen that is just taking
life extremely easy initially thought it
was a piece of a crocodile but if you
pan left you will see that the rest of
the body is kind of submerged with just
the head and the nose sticking out and
that is actually a really big crocodile
it's very hard to see because it's quite
submerged and the hippo thought that was
quite funny yes I don't think that's
infrasound at all that's just very loud
loud and interesting behavior I don't
know what they're saying I'd love to
know what they're saying there's only so
many notes that they use but there must
be some form of language in the hippo
there it tells all sorts of things like
I look at these tourists watching us
again don't they know the migration is
only in four or so months love to know
what hippos think when they're watching
us you can see that little pod of hippos
little family units the water is a lot
deeper here we just at the base of some
Rapids and it seems like there's a
little bit more water accumulated here
so a little bit more sort of suitable
habitat more territory for a bull and so
s Bianca hippos do make very cool sounds
and I wish what they were saying but it
is quite funny and it's quite
interesting but so what I was saying is
that the the hippos would this is what
it would be a small demarcated territory
of one maybe two bulls and having the
water the water is the territory the
water is the resource the females need
to submerge themselves in a female can
get a really nice pool a perennial pool
that is wet all year round and can keep
quite a number of females that is
prime location other areas that might
dry up aren't ideal and your weaker
Bulls would look after those areas and
then they don't obviously tracks as many
females the females want access to food
and on our way down to this crossing
there was huge amounts of Hippo paths
going in and out because they travel
quite large distances every night to
feed or depending on how much food there
is but they've been known to do round
trips of 60 kilometers so that's just
under 30 miles in the source of search
of food in one evening before coming
back to to these shallows to keep
themselves nice and cool from the hot
Sun and having these territories and
these puddles is very very important for
the hippos survival wonderful crocodile
they're a lot smaller than the other one
so can you come again with that faith I
didn't get your message
okay copied so beautiful crocodile but
we are going to be leaving this area
shortly and navigating further down the
stream and while we do so we're going to
be going all the way back to South
Africa to my good friend Noelle and see
what she has for you who won all right
we're over here in the big beautiful
open areas that are just on the southern
side of chitwa chitwa Lodge and we have
some impala males that are busy fighting
I just want to come around the corner a
little bit so we can get as unobstructed
of view as possible so that we can watch
that here we go how's that Ferg is that
okay - very good size males - decent
size males I don't think that they're
fighting to the death at the moment I
think it's more of testosterone-filled
and lots of ladies around here they come
again one of the reasons why I say I
don't think it's to the death it's
because one keeps running away now I do
just mmm it's hard because we've got
this tree that's in the way so I kind of
want to move forward but I don't cuz I
don't want to miss any of the action now
if this was ready in season you would be
seeing a much heavier black you would
hear it a little bit more with their
horns and you would also see them really
really really going at it because there
we go
let's see if we can hear
see if we can hear again side there
I hope you you all can hear this it's
like if you take two sticks and like hit
them hit them together so um elephant
tusks hitting each other's sound like
two big broomsticks hitting each other
and then what this sounds like is two
thin sticks that are very rigid and when
you smack them together that's what it
sounds like very cool so if this was
ready in season they would be trying to
kill each other to a point but they also
for dominance over these females right
now they're just exercising and getting
themselves ready for rutting season that
will happen in what month are we and now
we're almost in fab so in the next few
months
and of course the grin behind the tree
let me just roll forward
you're saying it seems as if the Royal
Rumbles on today I like that comment
that's a really great comment I enjoyed
that one eeek there this is a little bit
of a better view
now I also just heard now a little bit
of Thunder rolling in the distance which
is making me happy however that being
said I feel like the clouds are not
coming towards us I feel like they're
going more towards Kruger and north to
thorny bush and Tim bhavani but
hopefully tomorrow and I just also want
you guys to know so here's the Mail's
here if we go to the left a lot of the
females are over there not paying any
attention they really don't care at
these two males are fighting so these
males are not just fighting to condition
themselves but it's also for the ladies
saying look at me look at me like they
don't care and there's a couple other
males that are in there like yeah yeah
yeah you two go at it
a lot of beautiful wind and a few bird
calls that are popping through but the
wind keeps carrying them away all right
so now I'm Paul our herd animals similar
to those giraffes that we saw earlier
and you'll get females and herds with
dot lots of females and youngsters and
then you'll get Bachelor herds of males
the collective noun for Impala is a rank
of Impala and then this time of year you
get lots of mixed herd so males mixed in
with the females as we get closer to
rutting season you will start to see the
defined bachelor herds and defined
breeding herds and the breeding herds
will have one male attached to him but
usually that only lasts for a few
minutes during the middle of rutting
season because all they do is fight and
mate they don't eat they don't sleep
they just carry on we've got a vehicle
that will be passing by us shortly so
sorry about the noise
scarlet you'd like to know if I've ever
seen an Impala injured while fighting
I have scarlet there was a male Impala
on one of the properties I used to work
at whose horn grew funny it grew out
sideways and he used to take that horn
and shove it in to the rib cages and
sides of the other male impala and
killed them so yeah I have I've seen
that for this is great footage notice
how they look at each other when they're
getting in there and they're also trying
to sort of one-up each other as well as
not get there
I really fight horn on horn but
something like a kudu that's got really
really curly curly horns does more
posturing so a more sort of chest puffy
now look at me I'm so big as opposed to
actually trying to hit with the horns
because they can get stuck and if those
curly horns get stuck then they can die
like that I have never found impala
horns stuck together but I have seen
males fighting like this and once
they're like that had leopard come and
kill them and then the one that the
leopard killed the horns got stuck into
the other one the other one couldn't get
away she also killed that one as well
amazingly enough
I really aren't giving you all a very
good show now these two males are in
very good Nick I know we've all been
worried about the lack of rain the side
and myself and Scot and Tristan and I'm
sure everyone else as well has been
chatting about it quite a bit something
that's important to remember about
impalas and Paolo are mixed feeders so
they eat leaves and grass and right now
the conditions are really only affecting
the grass instead of instead of the
trees and the grass similar to our
drought that we had a couple of years
ago now where we are in chitwa they had
a lot more rain during that big storm
than we did we just got a little
sprinkly and they got some proper rain
all right these two seem to be taking a
little bit of a break and as I say that
of course here they go again but Scott
has a tiny little mammal that he would
like to show you so I think let's head
on over to him thanks Noel we've got a
wonderful scene here this is an animal
that we very very seldom see other than
a fleeting glimpse they're usually quite
shy but the slender mongoose has got a
good reason why it's hanging around here
we got alerted to its presence by some
starlings of which you can hear them all
alarming now that's them showing their
disapproval of the slender Mongoose and
as you can see there's a dead scrub air
and we can only guess that the slender
Mongoose has been feeding on the scrub
here it looks like it's hardly being fed
on it looks like it's almost very fresh
I haven't had a good look at it yet Reed
literally stopped the vehicle as soon as
we saw both the scrub here and the
slender Mongoose it's keeping honestly
in the Mongoose David is on the move
there it goes it's a black mamba that
killed the spell that killed the scrub
and the black mambas going up the tree
industry and the Mongoose is attacking
it's this is absolutely ridiculous
up above Davey there we go look at this
a ginormous black mamba and that
explains exactly why the scrub a looks
quite fresh this Mamba would have just
killed it and I'm guessing the slender
Mongoose responded to the scene because
of the alarm calls from the birds
oh my shattered nerves and I think we
should definitely welcome on board as
many other people as we can see this
fascinating scene I saw the mongoose
running and then I just sort kind of
bited something and it actually tried to
bite the tail of this black mamba I
thought it was trying to make another
kill at first and then I saw this all
mighty serpent starts slithering about
good grief now I was telling Dave as we
approach the sighting please could it be
a big snake please could it not just be
a slender mungus have a look at the
slender Mongoose below there Dave
directly below it's on the dead stamp it
down a bit it just jumped down but it
was standing kind of looking up at the
black mamba and isn't this a wonderful
wonderful kind of David and Goliath
display here the slender Mongoose looks
like it's trying to work its way higher
up this tree I'm gonna reposition ever
so slightly
hello everyone who has just joined us on
this unscheduled Safari broadcast as you
can see there is a snake up in that tree
and it is a Black Mamba one of the most
highly venomous snakes that we see in
Africa my name's Scott and it's great to
have you on board with us well let's
take a closer look at the snake as I
explained to you what exactly is going
on here
now we were driving along peacefully
it's a cool cloudy afternoon and hoping
to find something interesting when we've
heard some birds alarm calling it was
mainly the starlings that clearly were
letting us know that there weren't happy
about something so he drove into this
area and looks like the snakes trying to
move and I just want it it's quite
tricky there's an other predator on the
scene let's show you the the slender
mongoose quickly david's just that kind
of nine o'clock there and this was the
first predator we actually saw this tiny
little slender mongoose and i thought oh
well as per normal there's no sign of
any snakes but just two slender mongoose
but then we spotted something else a
dead scrub here and it looked quite
fresh to us but I wasn't too sure
exactly what was going on it looks like
the slender Mongoose was one she wanting
to steal it from the snake can you
actually believe what's happening here
so this tiny little scrubby would have
been caught by the snake and this
Mongoose is not trying to steal it now
we need to keep a close eye on quite a
few moving parts now I'm trying to work
out where the snake has gone it started
slithering down the tree and with snakes
we we've learned that they can disappear
so quickly there's no sign of it in the
tree any more that I can see and who
knows will this Black Mamba put up the
fight against the slender Mongoose which
is definitely far smaller than its I'm
guessing that black mamba was about
three meters in length but the Mongoose
is showing an incredible display of its
strength as it drags what will be an
absolute bargain of a meal for it it's
gonna keep this mongoose fed for days
now because we see snakes so seldom
million because that Mongoose isn't
gonna be able to move too quickly I'm
gonna try and just get us into a spot
where we can work out where this snake
is gone
let's hope it doesn't slither up into
the vehicle like I said this is one of
the most venomous snakes that we do get
Archer in Africa it's got a highly
highly cytotoxic sorry neurotoxic venom
that against that essentially that will
essentially just shut down your organs
causing you to die but I don't think
we're gonna get ourselves into any
trouble just yet now I can't for the
life of me see where the snake has gone
but let's just top stuff and see if we
can't have a scan in these bushes it
could well have disappeared into any
kind of cavities or holes ad you've just
mentioned that you've been hoping to see
a black mamba for many a safari and this
is the first one you've managed to see
with us I'm glad we managed to work that
one out for you where could it have gone
hmm it's incredible how such a big snake
can disappear so quickly and there's not
really that much undergrowth for it to
hide in let's keep driving around this
kind of falling down tree and see if we
can't get a view of its
my heart is absolutely erasing as I'm
sure a lot of yours are as well so much
excitements out of the blue and that is
the joy of being on a live Safari I
didn't have time to mention where we are
and what's going on we are in South
Africa in the sabi sands reserve at the
moments and this is a live Safari if you
have not gathered that already no
immediate sign of this slithering
serpents it could just be kind of curled
up in a ball somewhere hoping we get
some more views of it but the snake is a
territorial snake so it'll know this
area well and I'm guessing it would have
worked out and remembered a good place
to slither off to and I'm guessing it's
somewhere at the base of this tree it
looks like there could be a few hiding
places a few holes in and around that
root system there sure know where has
the Mongoose dragged the scrubby ooh I
can see the little Mongoose I think we
may have disturbed it ever so slightly
but seeing as though it has just stolen
this meal from the snake I'm not too
concerned for the time being and it will
come back immediately to where the scrub
here is I'm guessing it's somewhere just
in front of us over here so what we
should do is get into a good spots and
kind of just sits and patiently wait to
see if we can't get any more views of
the snake as well as the slender
Mongoose starting to snap down on the
scrub here hoo-wee
absolutely awesome awesome stuff and
seeing as though things seem to have
calmed down for the time being I'm
thinking of saying goodbye to everyone
who has just temporarily joined us and
if you would like to continue
joining on this afternoon Safari you can
just google Safari live and kept find us
quite easily that way thanks very much
we'll see you all next time
welcome back everyone whoo that was
absolutely crazy and such a good example
of how you just never know what is going
to happen our chair I can't believe the
snake gave us the slip I was really
hoping we were gonna be able to get some
more views of it but I think if we
positioned the vehicle in their ice
spots and just sits in wait patiently we
could well see the snake coming out to
investigate what has happened to its
hard-earned meal what I do know is that
these creatures can just move so so
quickly that sometimes they give us the
slip with relative ease but I'm sure a
lot of you are ecstatic that we finally
got a decent snake sighting in we see
them so seldom Lee and I'm very very
happy that finally our luck has turned
cool yeah thanks davyous butter their
dad was just letting me know where the
little scrub is we've got a view of that
we're gonna just get into a good spot
where we can wait and watch the Mongoose
come back and start doing its thing and
all hopefully see what the snake is
getting up to so while we do that we are
going to send you off to one of the
others bit they're feeling jealous about
our wonderful sighting unbelievable
Scottie I can't believe you saw what you
saw
first of all seeing a member second
while seeing a slender Mongoose and
third of all I'm gonna see that footage
when I get back because that's just
ridiculous I don't have as much action
as you guys did there but we are down at
one of the major crossings I would
ascertain on the Mara River by the fact
that the slopes are very very gentle and
there are one two three four five six
seven but not a ten of the biggest
crocodiles you'll ever come across just
susume on the bank they are enormous
those are all really really big
crocodiles you can see a baboon at the
back there I think they call olive
baboons they were walking past and I
come in too close there's some
youngsters on top they having a little
look down you would wouldn't you
that's what we're doing right now
yeah we're just peering but we know we
know in our inside ourselves that going
any closer is just silly I remember
being on a walk once up in Mackay Lake
in puffery and I was leading and about
30 meters in front of me a crocodile
stood up on the bank like it is now it
was in front of us stood up and sort of
walked kind of towards us but it wasn't
really towards us it was kind of trying
to turn around to go back into the water
and just that moment of it moving that
scent terrors through my soul everything
about that animal moving and towards you
and looking at you is frightening I
don't think we need to be taught that I
think we know that instinctively our
body just knows I mean look at that that
is prime evil they have been around for
so
so long that any ancestor of ours knows
very well with the crocodiles capable of
beautiful really really big ones these I
mean the biggest recorded crocodile was
five and a half meters so what's that
such work the doubt try to work that out
I've apologized it's very long five and
a half meters in in in feet is Tom's
three I think yeah fifteen sixteen feet
make it 18 feet that is huge
yes crocodiles Wow and you know they
feed on fish as I said before but you
know there are reptiles so they spend
their time in the Sun and they don't
need metabolic energy like we do so they
don't need to eat all the time
even if if they just had of all the best
every couple of months you know they
could probably go for an entire year
with one meal a proper meal and they
wouldn't have to eat again they don't
need the energy that we use to expend to
run around and do our thing
they just have to lie there in that the
Sun do all the work for them and when
they're really hungry I want to be
active then they get up and go in the
water and catch some fish or just wait
yeah as is going to happen and it's
probably happened for for however many
years they've all the Bears have been
crossing these exact places and so why
go anywhere beautiful my River
scarlet asks why do they have their
mouths open and they're cooling down
they are reptiles so they rely on the
ambient temperatures to heat them up and
when they get a little bit hot then just
like the birds do they open their mouth
and let the wind push over their there
their mouth and then it cools them down
it doesn't require any effort for them
to open their mouth it actually requires
muscle to close the mouth so they're
having the mouth open up that is
actually the the relaxed relaxed sort of
stage but they are enjoying themselves
on the bank there wouldn't want to be
oval the beasts trying to cross this
little pond
Katie asks a question ah is a true
crocodiles of to a tortoise I don't know
my honest he actually don't know that
question I don't know the answer to that
question there's a lot about the
internal organs of a crocodile I don't
know about but I'll definitely look that
up what I'm not sure you'd have to have
two hearts to have two a tortoise
wouldn't you yes no Katie I'm sorry I'm
not sure you are sir I reckon you're
five and a half meters it's close to
about 18 feet 18 feet and a thousand
kilograms so that is close to 2,000
pounds can you imagine trying to swim in
the river here with his extremely large
animals that don't need to eat but will
their prehistoric I remember my tracker
telling me the only animal he's afraid
of as a crocodile because he does I've
got no instinct as good as no rationale
with him most trekkers afraid of any
badges as I've said but they are afraid
of crocodiles but we're going to move on
from our probably our last view of the
Mara River this afternoon we're gonna go
over to Jamie who I believe is with that
wolololo the all alors are starting to
lift their heads up they are showing
signs that they are going to get up and
perhaps start moving about maybe even
have a drink from this rather I guess
I'd call it fitted puddle that's in
front of them it doesn't look
particularly appetizing to drink from
but Lions won't be too fussy about where
they drink obviously like all animals
they will prefer fresh water met
elephants of course are the ones who are
famous for really enjoying and actually
actively searching for fresh water over
stagnant water but in this case I don't
think it will stop them we go another
one strolled over sitting up blinking in
the harsh sunset that's very peculiar
back how very odd
thank you money apparently my voice
disappeared briefly apologies for that
but we're back again
no idea how that happened
David quite possibly yes but you'd have
to go back quite far away so far back
inside what's biting you far back down
the line so David's question is are the
and the order laws related to the
sausages
there is often a possibility with with
lion prides that at some point way back
in history they might actually have been
related to each other and that they sort
of came came about through a split in a
larger pride it's impossible for us to
know that for certain
yes the sausages are the immediate
neighbors to the older law laws but
territories for lion prides do shift
around a little bit the females are sort
of the generational guardians of an area
so a pride might shift around a little
bit you know a couple of miles here a
couple of miles there down the
generations they might be under pressure
from other males but a lot of the time
they'll actually stay in quite a similar
area for a few generations at least
which means that there is a possibility
what has got you what what is biting you
did you sit an ant nest by any chance
little man it's just something's biting
it and I just can't get comfortable
really quite officers too frustrating
for words
no it's bolted over to the other knee
hold it cub so we see some sort of fly
but a bite potentially biting fly or
perhaps a stinging insect of some
description oh now look what you've done
no there's more looks like flies to me
roadblock no roadblock is a perhaps new
to to these live safaris and wondering
well where are the male lions are they
not with the females the truth is that
male lions are not part of a pride and
it's something that I think is a very
very powerful misconception that males
must be part of a lion pride and that
they're always with the females think of
it this way a male lion or a group of
male lions known as a coalition they
have a big territory and that territory
can encompass the territories of several
different groups of females now those
males have an important job to do they
have to patrol that territory they have
to keep other males out and while there
may be the fathers of these Cubs there
they have to make sure that they are
protected from strange males entering
their territory that means they're often
off on their own
often they split up even if they do
belong to a coalition they'll wonder
about they'll mark their territory and
then now come and visit the females and
they'll often visit the females when
there's food involved male lions are
more capable of hunting at their own
dinner or breakfast or lunch or whatever
it happens to be whatever time of the
day but they are not adverse to allowing
the females to do the work for them and
then going and joining in often taking
what's known as the lion's share of the
milk and will also help with that if
they can if they come upon the females
while they're hunting so they'll go to
mate to eat occasionally just for the
company but they are not always with the
females often they're with different
prides and there's no there's no nest
there's no reason why they might choose
to be here with the females there's
plenty of other things for them to be
doing and actually you'll probably find
that they prefer to be away while these
just gonna sit here because as you can
see Cubs don't necessarily have a sense
of personal space lines of bed with
personal space as it is but Cubs love to
go and flop on each other might be a
little bit irritating to the males but
look out that's a male that's a young
male cub
please forgive me if I've got the name
wrong I think faith said Aaron but it
might have been that parent parent a cow
wasn't sure
Paran now Paran is 10 years old and it's
lovely to hear that you are watching the
live Safari parent now here we go we've
got the subject of the question from
parent can lions swim Paran yes they can
most of the mammal species out here can
swim some better than others obviously
and some like it more than others
elephants love swimming for example and
that's partly because I don't think they
knew they don't have to really worry
about things like crocodiles they're too
big to be threatened by them so lions do
swim they can swim they often swim
across that Mara River Steve was at the
Mara River earlier he was showing you
the various animals around there the
Lions often swim across the Mara River
if they need to they don't like doing it
though there's no real indication that
lions particularly like it and that's
probably actually mainly because they're
scared of being eaten by a crocodile
crocodiles don't distinguish between a
lion or an antelope or a zebra whatever
else they would be looking for to make
their next meal lovely to hear from your
parent parent I'm excited to hear what
question you come up with next
gone Lions there's a tree right there
I've been told so many things about your
fantastic tree climbing ability you know
you want to it's right there
a squat a scarlet I have been in the
position where I've been able to touch
her lines for both adults and Cubs
that's something that I've spoken about
in the past about the the problem with
cub hitting but Scarlet of course is
wanting to know about the softness of a
lion cubs fur mine's fur is surprisingly
course except around the base of the
ears you know the soft paths on a house
cats around the base of the ears around
underneath the arms the arms the legs
the front legs around the armpits it's
call on that that's where the softest
fur is on a line but Lions fur is very
coarse it's very functional it needs to
be it's there for a reason and obviously
if it was too soft and fine it would
cause all sorts of problems that could
become matted and uncomfortable and full
of parasites that would be entangled in
it well their affair is quite coarse as
a young lion cubs well I've never
touched a very young line cut before and
I am ashamed to say that in the past
before I knew better I did touch an
older cover got to play with an older
cub before I realized that I was very
young but before I realized the full
detriment of what I was doing and how
absolutely unnecessary it is and how
unfortunate the future of those Cubs
that are raised for for people to pet
actually truly is I can tell you that it
isn't not it's not as soft as a kittens
fur we're going to sit patiently with
our lines and see if they decide to get
up to some tree climbing exploits but
while they sleep let's jump back on
board and join Noel in the back of I
think she's on Wendy so we had set up
this really nice view of a vulture and
then also and we could hear kudu barking
so we've just come into the block a
little bit and we found our kudu but we
they're relaxed now so the wind is
coming strongly and then circling around
so I'm wondering if they're smelling
something that they just can't quite see
so I think you know we'll stick with our
kudu for a little while we're not far
from the last area where we were seeing
tündi and we haven't seen her in a
couple of days and it's very good
weather for leopards to one be hunting
about and to just moving because it's
much cooler than it has been
now this cooter is a really interesting
mark on her back there
her stripes are very different look all
stripy and patterns are unique but
that's a little abnormal sort of loop
it's made they're very cool and of
course a resident oxpecker to help the
kudu with any possible sightings of
predators as well as to pick her on the
bum area as you can see and take off
ticks and parasites now something that
those oxpeckers will do other than
consuming the ticks and the the blood as
we talked about earlier there you can
hear it a little maybe sorry the winds
just picked up they were alarmed calling
just a little bit there but if there is
something like say us on foot or a
predator of some kind walking around
those oxpeckers will fly up an alarm
call and it warns the kudu or Impala or
a rhino or buffalo that they happen or
giraffe that they happen to be on that
something's amiss it's also a sound that
we as walking guides need to really keep
track of because if you don't you could
possibly end up in a scenario that you
don't want to be in you always listen
out for oxpeckers red and yellow build
we get both in the area now kudos are
meant for camouflage so that's striping
even just the odd pattern we saw before
but the striping pattern on the side is
- it's called a disruptive marking it's
to break up the body shade of body shape
of the animal so when they get nervous
or something they'll sort of freeze
behind a bush and that's supposed to
help and then also when they run off
they've got this white under the tail
that they'll lift the tail up and run
and jump and it's supposed to be one of
two things one it's supposed to be a
follow-me signal for other kudu and then
to the thought behind that is that
they'll run and the predator will focus
on that and then turn around a corner
and then drop their tail and then the
predator doesn't have anything to focus
on now Alois I believe you are asking do
we have different rain season patterns
like the Mara like the Mara it's got big
rains and
rains here in Juma or do we just have
one rainy season I think that's the
question I heard if I heard it properly
now we have one rainy si
okay we're Ferg oh sorry I believe Scots
mambas doing something interesting let's
go to him and we'll finish this later
yes the member has come back art we can
just see it slithering very slowly
through the grass there and it is
approaching the slender mongoose with
its scrub hair kill it early upon it
hold its head up about fifty centimeters
off the ground peering towards the scrub
vehicle let's just show everyone the
scrub hair killed quickly we can just
see a little white a little white spot
there that is the scrub his tail and I
think the slender Mongoose is still
there I can't be certain the snakes
about the snakes about the snakes there
the snakes there fighting with the the
Mongoose let's just stay tight like that
Dhabi and all the mongoose is going for
the snake oh it's just so thick and I
don't want to try and reposition any
closer whew there we can go we can see
the snake there again now only just we
can see the snake slithering through the
undergrowth and has the Mongoose given
in absolutely epic epic stuff law I am
going to try to reposition us a little
bit closer I think we can get into
slightly better spots I'm just gonna
move very slowly how absolutely awesome
is this no I'm gonna stop here and just
see if that doesn't help for the time
being it's not ideal but I really don't
want to impact on what's going on if you
go to the right a little bit more Davi I
think the snakes more to the right
there's its tail and
welcome back to everyone who has just
joined us on this unscheduled broadcast
we've got a fascinating scene unfolding
in front of us there is a black mamba
you can see there it's tail is
slithering through the undergrowth
it's a highly venomous snake probably
the most venomous in Africa and it's had
one of its killed stolen by a much
smaller predator slender mongoose and it
seems to be there's the kill there it's
a scrubber that it managed to catch and
kill and it seems to be trying to
reclaim this from the Mongoose the
Mongoose is still here somewhere
it's just so thick and we really don't
want to impact on what's going on yeah
but I am going to try and squeeze us a
few meters further forward we are coming
to you live from the sabi sands in South
Africa my name's Scott and it's great to
have you on board with us absolutely
incredible stuff we spend hours and
hours out in this wilderness daily but
seldom do we get to see fascinating
scenes like this I'm just going to stop
here and see if we can't snipe a little
gap through there it looks like if you
keep goo zooming in but oh there's the
slender mongoose
so the slender mongoose is playing with
fire here because if the snake does land
of just one bites onto a small mammal
like this it will be only a matter of
seconds before it dies serve an
incredible jewel between a kind of a
David and Goliath scenario here this
mongoose is far smaller than the snake
and of course the snake is highly highly
venomous like I've said it doesn't seem
too concerned I just grooming its back
in between this jewel between the snake
the scrub here and this black mamba
where are you suggesting that kennis
mongoose not kill the snake in yes I
mean it could kill the snake but it
would be an almighty feat for it to be
able to kill it because it is a very
large and dangerous predator so earlier
on we saw the mongoose nip the snake on
the tail and chase it up a small bush
and it'll continue to try and Pistor the
snake but the snake is also backing
itself that's
has come back onto the scene here the
Mongoose is incredibly agile and it's
using that speed and agility to avoid
any strikes from the Mamba let's see if
I can move forward a little bit more and
get us a slightly better view as to
what's going on
okay the mom has got its head up having
a look at us now and it's called a black
mamba not because of the coloration of
its skin as you can see it's quite a
grayish color but more importantly
because it's got a peak
strikes its is pitch pitch black there
you can see it now biting onto the scrub
here and you may see a little bit of
kind of meat and blood there that's from
where the slender mongoose had started
to feed on the scrub a absolutely
incredible views of this highly highly
successful and venomous snake now what
is interesting is that the scrub here is
large so for the snake to swallow the
scrub it I think it just got a back from
the scrub a did you see how its bodies
moving like that I think as it starts to
start swallowing the the hair and it
needs to swallow it headfirst it's got
it by the head there the Mongoose sneaks
in and gives it a bite how absolutely
awesome is this everyone and the fact
that we are coming to you live makes it
that much sweeter please send through
your thoughts and your comments I would
love to hear how you guys are feeling
I'm feeling absolutely ecstatic because
to see something like this is incredibly
incredibly fortunate
Fiona you would like to know if there
are any animals that are possibly immune
to
to animals like mainly the honey badger
which is renowned for being incredibly
Hardy and tenacious and I have seen a
documentary where a puff adder also a
highly venomous snake attacked a badger
as the bunny badger was trying to attack
it and it did manage to biotin and a
honey badger just curled up and went to
sleep for a few hours woke up shook its
head as if it had a small hangover and
then continued to eat the puff adder
that it had killed so possibly honey
badgers other than that there are not
too many animals including a mammal our
size an adult human being will be in
deep trouble if they are bitten by this
snake it does attack your nervous system
and neurotoxic venom and slowly all your
organs will shut down Chris you've
mentioned that this is unbelievable and
I'm very happy to have you on board with
us I'm just going to try and creep
forward a meter not even just to try and
get a bit of view of the snake's head as
it continues to try and swallow the hair
here we go that's better and like I've
said it's got its work cut out for it
because it is an absolutely large prey
or much larger than I would've thought
possible for the snake to swallow but
they can unhinge their top and bottom
jaw and allow their very stretchy skin
to accommodate a very often large prey
and unlike a lot of other predators
snakes I guess and crocodiles don't have
the joy of being able to rip off
portions of their kill but in fact have
to swallow their prey whole
not so much crocodiles crocodiles can do
the spinning role where they all break
off pieces but they can't really chew
off bits they need to stretch them off
there's no further sign of the slender
mongoose which is interesting it may
have had a small snack and thought well
that's enough I don't want to risk any
more
Mumba ha well Katie you've got a very
interesting theory you're wondering if
this black mamba is not waiting for
oh sorry if the slender Mongoose is not
waiting for the black mamba to finish
the scrub here and then consume them
both to be honest I don't think that the
slender monkey sees a black mamba as its
prey I think it was just in the area
when this Mamba made the kill and
opportunistically try to steal it from
its v and nature is quite common
interestingly enough and a lot of the
Predators will compete with one another
and steal kills look at how its
stretching now absolutely awesome stuff
madellaine you are 100% correct this is
a once-in-a-lifetime sighting and yes
the snake will certainly swallow it
whole that's its only option really if
it gets halfway and gets stuck it will
have to regurgitate the the you know the
initial parts that it has swallowed
because they only have one option it is
all or nothing it doesn't have the
necessary teeth to chew off a chunk of
this scrub here
I wonder how the whole kill went down if
the snake followed the scent of this
scrub air and snuck up on its and just
gave it one well-positioned bites and it
would have been
I'm guessing within a minutes the
scrubby air would have died because it's
so small that the venom would have raced
through its body and cause death quite
quickly I'm gonna try and sneak a Ford a
little bit more Sarah you'd like to know
how long can a black mamba get and three
meters it is really big for one and but
possibly slightly bigger than that not
much though how's that looking there
Dave a little bit to the left I think so
looks like it's battling to get over the
skull but it's about to Carley you'd
like to know how can the snake breathe
whilst it's got its mouthful of scrubber
and you'll notice there's one tiny
nostril that we can see there and it
will be breathing through those nostrils
look all the ticks are fleeing there's
tiny little insects you can see on the
scrub here are small parasites and
fairly certain called ticks and they've
obviously realized that the hosters died
and are now thinking about another plan
more has the snake decided that the kill
is too large I think it has it's off it
goes Davey it's still doing away there
well then so
too big for the snake and how unlucky is
it but it's hard one meal I'm gonna try
and stay with it get you a few more
views
because we see them so infrequently the
tricky thing is they move so quickly
through this undergrowth and even though
there's not much cover I cannot believe
how quickly it can disappear it also
took us by surprise when it popped back
out very close to that kill we were
sitting waiting patiently and had no
idea where it came from
no I fear that even though we did move
quite quickly into the spot that we may
not get any more views of the Black
Mamba but if you would like to see if we
do you got asked and Google sapphire
life to continue following on this live
Safari it's been an absolute pleasure
having you for this incredibly
incredibly rare sighting of a slender
Mongoose and a black mamba we'll see you
all next time
welcome back everybody well I wasn't
that absolutely awesome shame poor snake
the scrubber that had decided to kill
was a little bit too big it appears and
you could see it was really just having
trouble getting that skull into its
mouth but I'm very very happy that we
got to share that fascinating scene with
all of you guys
apparently Ralph has now got a trick or
two up his sleeve why don't you go and
see what he has in store for you thanks
Scott and well everybody this is very
exciting exciting for us and exciting
for the predator that has taken this
little giraffe up the tree now we don't
have the best of visuals but there we
are
there is a lipid that has killed a
little baby giraffe and dragged it up
the tree we don't have a very clear view
on him or her Tyler seems to think that
it might be the Shepherd's tree mail but
not sure it's just because she's seen
him do this before so maybe a little
specialist in baby giraffe well he's
obviously better than those female lions
that we've been watching disappointedly
messing the warthogs well this guy's
obviously or her and obviously am been
very successful in the hunt and yeah
shine there we can see the leopard but
in the background
through the trees I don't know if we'll
be able to see it but mummy giraffe is
still hanging around so that's quite sad
for her she's there behind the trees
there somewhere we did have a view on a
minute ago she was walking around there
I think she's just behind the trees
there somewhere chime sure but she's
obviously pining for her little
youngster but very nice for the leopard
because now he's got a little cachet of
food for the
next few days unless there's a wily old
lion that could get up the tree there
cat here saying that this is amazing
there's a little bit of movement up in
the tree there I wonder if the leopards
making to move or if he's just it
getting a little bit more comfortable
that looks like its head yes and it's
panting we can see its nose just through
the brush now cat yes what a what an apt
name because this is such a beautiful
cat yeah and this is an immoral triangle
so this is my third lipid oh and we've
got a beautiful face shot there just
through the brush now we're not allowed
to drive off-road here so that's why I'm
not going any closer and it's probably a
good thing because there are a few
excited vehicles with people around so
I'm sure if we were allowed or fried
this this leopard would be a little bit
harassed
so was that rule it's a little bit worse
for us but better for the leopard which
I'm quite happy about everybody got to
keep the distance here
Pisces Bobby you're saying that this
must be heartbreaking for mommy giraffe
absolutely I mean you know all that
energy and everything put into having
this little baby but it does happen
quite a lot to a little baby giraffe
especially in the first year because
they're quite silly really in their
curiosity and you often find mommy
giraffe having to crawl a little baby
away from all sorts of predators and
even vehicles they sort of just go
walking up to them not really knowing
the danger and obviously they wouldn't
because they've just been born and they
don't understand that things can kill
them but mummies are kept very busy
trying to keep their little babies out
of danger well this one obviously didn't
make it but that does mean that the
leopard feeds and lives on for another
few days until it needs to find itself
something else so well done to the
leopard and unlucky to the giraffe I
wouldn't say that it's going to have an
impact on the pearl on the population of
giraffe now cat you're asking is a baby
giraffe a big prey for a leopard cat
absolutely it is a very big prey for a
leopard it's a massive prey for a lipid
so it's very important to remember that
we don't often get to see this it's it's
a wonderful encounter and as we just
zoom out there that was a wonderful
fleeting little experience that we've
had unfortunately it is our time to go
and head up the the escarpment and we're
not having the best visuals but what a
wonderful into the drive I would say
that was absolutely fantastic and I
think I'm going to be coming back here
tomorrow morning first thing to see if
we can catch up and see if this lipid is
still yeah maybe there'll be a lion
that's gone up the tree and pulled it
out who'll know who knows but yeah we're
going to have to start
and start making our way up the
escarpment so well that was a
last-minute leopard for me so everyone
as I leave this leopard and head up the
escarpment please join us tomorrow
morning again
because I'm coming straight back here
but as I go on my way I'm gonna hit you
on back down to South Africa and the
beautiful Narwhal
hi everyone I've got a treat for you I
have a bird of prey that I cannot ID so
there's no feathers all the way down the
legs the legs are yellow it has a yellow
seer that hard across the top with a
black tip and a very distinctive eye
markings underneath and around to the
side of the gape there it calls there
and when it opens its wings and it flies
it's really windy right now
it was very distinctive markings on
underneath the closest I've gotten is a
juvenile African hawk eagle yeah I think
that's what I decided on let me just I'm
gonna find it in the book for you but if
we have any serious birders out there
that are watching please any thoughts
you have would be greatly greatly
appreciated finding one
and then I was also possibly thinking I
just want to find these photos for you
so you can see why I'm thinking it's the
way that I'm thinking but this is super
exciting it's also sitting on this tree
here with a white back to vulture and
we've been seeing a lot of vultures so
Ferg and I have been checking out the
the drainage lines here where tündi was
sort of last seen so here's that African
hawk eagle this one here so this is the
adult yeah
on the left okay
now this is the juvenile here and then
over on the side there we go well guys
well I'm trying to discuss this bird
with you I'm just going to say goodbye
to all of you who have been watching
with us on the specialized platforms and
we hope you enjoyed and don't forget to
a google safari live so that you can
keep following